No!
The truth of the matter is,...
...he's always in a bad mood.
But when he was on his phone and got texts or calls...
...or just about anything else interrupted him,...
...really, really bad mood.
He must be going through puberty.
But lately, I've seen some changes.
He texts with his friends while he's watching soccer.
Amazing, right?
And while he's watching movies, he follows his favorite team on Facebook.
He can search the web while he plays games.
And all that seems to make him happy.
What are you looking at?
Well, it makes him happier than before.
So sometimes he shares his phone with me.
It must be his hormones.
You have a girlfriend?
Ready, set, multiplayer!